[Music]
[Applause]
uh Mike Ryan is joining us on behalf of
NBC Sports Sunday Night Football sports
medicine analyst he was on the sidelines
at Arrowhead when Patrick Mahomes got
injured and he was behind the bench he
was working with Melissa Stark and uh he
has been in the medical uh the uh
training Community athletic training
experience for more than 30 years is
that fair to assess what you've done
Mike well said Dan almost almost okay
playing with that kind of injury in the
moment as opposed to a week later for
Patrick Mahomes
well it's easy firsthand because
obviously it's a difficult thing this is
a high ankle spray not a lateral ankle
sprain but he's all fired up you know
he's the ultimate competitor uh they
taped his ankle got the confirmation
that the x-rays are negative so in the
moment
um it is easy to deal with easier I
should say a week later is a whole
different situation pain sets in
the realization of what you can do uh I
think this weekend is going to be a
tougher task that we saw him in the
second half last Saturday okay what do
you think now he was running on it a
little bit or stretching yesterday which
isn't a true indication I don't think of
anything there but does can this get
better or does this get worse as we get
closer to game time
well with a high ankle sprain because
it's a rotational issue when you rotate
and you spread the bones of the lower
Shin that's the sprain that's a high
ankle sprain well the running straight
ahead is the easy part the problem is
when you're twisting you see him
twisting off that leg anytime you see
Dan that foot rotate outwards when he's
throwing hard when he's cutting to his
left side coming off that right ankle
that's a difficult challenge so walking
him watching him walk off the podium
watching him run straight on the
football field with no Bengals chasing
him is a much different task and
obviously a lot easier than when he has
to change direction and really be an
agile quarterback which what he is when
you get shot up explain that what
exactly happens or what happened do you
think to Mahomes uh when when he
suffered the injury well I don't think
he was shot up and sometimes the players
get a little confused with that is they
may have taken a shot or got shot for it
but usually what that is again I'm not
speaking specifically on Patrick is a
Toradol injection and they usually put
that into the glutes it's a fast-acting
anti-inflammatory so sometimes you hear
people get shot off for the game
and the reality is they took a
injectionable anti-inflammatory much
much different this is not an injury
that you would shoot up to play in the
game uh there are instances when you get
a high ankle sprain because again it is
a tearing of the membrane of the lower
Shin that you can inject it with a PRP
or stem cell and you shut it down in a
boot or a cast for a few weeks and let
that medicine marinate in there it's a
treatment it's not numbing things up
like the old uh North Dallas Forty where
you put a needle in it and throw them
back in the game this is a very
different injury and that doesn't happen
very often in the NFL for injuries like
this there are certain injuries you can
but um again it's not like it used to be
and now really they use good Physical
Therapy techniques which rip work out of
the head off on a trainer for the the uh
Chiefs is very very good at this and
treating them that way with physical
therapy techniques compared to a needle
is a much smarter plant both short term
and long-term if this was a regular
season game this weekend let's say week
eight
do you think Patrick Mahomes would be
playing
well I think he'd want to play he's the
ultimate competitor he wants to get out
there but I think looking at it look at
the issues know what's a long season
mid-season I I think you see Chad
Henning starting this game but again
this is the AFC Championship game uh the
stakes are a lot higher and I I think
you'd you need a bulldozer to get
Patrick off the field this weekend how
often do players lie to trainers
all the time all the time players want
to play they want to get on the field
they want to kind of water things down
and especially if you're winning Dan if
if you're in a winning streak and
everybody wants to get on the field
winning solves a lot of problems well
like sometimes we've had in Jacksonville
when things aren't going well and you're
losing games guys sometimes may want to
find a reason to get off the field so
but but ultimately the players are going
to want to play and I think a lot of
times they'll uh they give you a line
but sometimes you have to go back and
test them and make sure they can do it
you don't take a subjective feedback for
what they think they can do yourself
medically as a physical therapist the
coaches coordinators they want to see it
and I think that's the important part
what you really work on during the week
before you get to Sunday worst injury
you ever saw
um probably the most graphic one of
probably the most interesting I've seen
a lot of them is uh remember Chris
Hanson our punter in Jacksonville put a
ax into the front of his shin uh in the
locker room we had a jack that we had
the big blog and said keep chopping and
guys are whacking it but one time he
missed the log and hit his shin and came
in and his shin was wide open oh God
that that was a memorable injury that uh
is kind of hard to forget
but he's a punter and you can easily
replace them yeah
pitch him up oh yeah yeah but he cut
through a lot of the ligaments and a lot
of the tendons blood vessels
that was uh it was ugly he missed the
air but he came back and played uh
probably uh four or five more years
again it was his plant leg which is a
little bit easy to deal with but a tough
guy and uh not not your average uh
punter if you will did he get to keep
the ax
no no they uh they took the ax away and
uh that that log in the locker room was
uh gone about 20 minutes later can a
trainer pull a player
yes absolutely you had the authority to
say uh this guy should come out yes this
guy shouldn't go back in because the
reality again as an Athleta trainer you
spend more time with that player
especially if they're an injured player
than anyone else in the building so you
know them you know the personalities you
know what they can do you're you kind of
watch the game very differently compared
to the typical fan you see how guys move
you see how they hit you're always
looking for those those risk factors if
you will but yeah if you say he has to
be out you're going to get a fight from
the player you may get a fight from the
coach
But ultimately concussions are a great
example you get players that have an
injury they have something like that a
concussion they're not thinking straight
so they may say I can go but you have to
you have to jump on that hand grenade
many times uh for the players and
ultimately nine times out of ten that
player will come back later on and say
thank you but In the Heat of the game uh
there's no uh such nice verbal language
to you in a lot of times what role would
you have played with Tua when he was
suffering the concussion Ori had the
moment where his back went out like what
you know when you see that happening
what role does the head trainer have
a lot of it again you know the players
you have to sometimes you have to
sprinkle common sense and you say hey
look what you saw
um there are many times a player has
passed a a concussion exam and I'd have
to lie to the coach and say look he's
not ready his balance is off something's
not there
um and my Lana used to use with the
players is when they're all fired up
they'll say Hey listen
three years from now I want to make sure
you remember the names of your kids and
that's a good way for the player you
would lie to the coach you would lie to
the coach to say you know he's a little
unstable there you're trying to protect
the player from going to attack the
player exactly you have to sometimes you
have to protect the player for what they
have and what they can go because
they're going to want to get in the
field but the reality is should they be
on the field that's uh that's the
ultimate question but you have to
protect the players you have to keep the
players safe in a very violent game
whenever I think of that high ankle
sprain I always think of Isaiah Thomas
against the Lakers when he had that
unbelievable game and he was hobbling
around but that's in the moment that
somehow your body what does your body do
to protect itself when you suffer these
injuries
well endorphins start ripping through
your body and it gets your your mind all
kind of geeked up so you kind of focus
on the task at hand you kind of downplay
it the old
um mindset almost not that bad so you
keep these positive affirmations that
these players use all the time to say
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine and you get
the moment you get the crowd you got
your teammates you got the scoreboard
you have a lot of motivational factors
to get on the field but in the morning
when you wake up and you start doing the
rehab and the swelling is set in like a
lot of times with a high ankle sprain
Dan you can't truly diagnose until 12
hours later
because that membrane may feel good at a
moment but then the next day when the
swelling sets in so the morning after a
bad ankle sprain is when you can really
truly diagnose and say this is a high
angle spray sometimes you're surprised
for the better most times you're
surprised for the worst because it comes
back worse in the morning than when they
left the stadium the night before could
you give me a concussion test
I could like a verbal
uh verbal a a great one is like eye
testing
because putting your fingers out in
front of you and keep your head still
and look focus on one finger then focus
on the other and go back and forth and
really focus on that it's a great way
where your eyes have to converge on an
object at different distances in front
of you and if you start doing that if
your symptoms are coming around
concussion Wise from a visual issue
which is very common for football
players suddenly as you do that after 30
seconds to a minute your concussion
symptoms will come back
it's a very good way as you're watching
the eyes you know the eyes moving
smoothly figuring or finger where they
start jumping sometimes the eyes are
really the key to show of something
behind uh behind the forehead is not
working properly what would you do
verbally
um right as soon as they got concussed
you get into silent I would just give
them three random words apple tree
bicycle remember those words then we go
through the exams they go into the blue
tent they talk to the neurologist they
go through all the stuff and then they
come back to them say hey what were
those three words I gave you and they're
like what words
so you're now what you're doing Dan
you're testing the memory after they got
concussed which is very different and
then you'd ask a question like what'd
you have for breakfast
um what was the score last week and who
did we play two weeks ago so now you're
having them start to look at short-term
memory since the concussion what I did
three or four hours before the game two
or three weeks earlier so you start
testing their ability to memorize or
know things from different time lapses
it's a real simple way of making sure
that the brain is working functionally
especially for a guy like a a skilled
player well if they can't remember that
how can they remember their place how
can they track a ball you know coming
through the sky at 45 miles an hour so
there's a lot of things you can test on
the sideline to make sure can they go on
the field and do their job because first
things first for the player Dan they
have to be able to protect themselves
regardless of their position
does anybody remember all three words
there yes
no I'm asking my guys because I'm going
you know
um I remembered Apple
fritzy tree was involved okay involved
apple tree that I don't remember the
third one yeah bicycle
we did it yeah all right we're not
welcome because collector out of the
concussion program yeah yeah we get to
go back in uh great stuff Mike thank you
for sharing we appreciate it my pleasure
Dan thank you that's uh Mike Ryan a
medical analyst for uh NBC football
night in America more than 30 years of
athletic training experience with uh the
NFL college